un primer aviso a rusia en la era byd en
eeuu en coordinación con la unión
europea sancionó a siete funcionarios
cercanos al presidente vladimir putin
también castigaron a 14 empresas rusas
que participan en la producción de
agentes químicos y biológicos el uso de
cualquier arma química viola
directamente las obligaciones legales
internacionales y las normas de conducta
civilizadas y nuestras acciones de hoy
responden a una serie de categorías que
reflejan la total respuesta del gobierno
es la respuesta al encarcelamiento en
enero del opositor alexéi navalni así
como de su intento de asesinato mediante
envenenamiento con no que en
agosto de 2020 estas primeras sanciones
suponen un cambio respecto a las
políticas del ex presidente de donald
trump quien siempre mostró simpatía
hacia su homólogo vladimir putin y que
decidió no sancionar a rusia tras el
envenenamiento de naval y cuando no hay
nada que presentar para fundamentar sus
afirmaciones sobre el envenenamiento de
naval ni comienzan a castigarnos
definitivamente responderemos
pero además pueden llegar más sanciones
en el futuro desde el gobierno
estadounidense están evaluando el papel
que tuvo rusia en el ciberataque masivo
de solarwinds también las sospechas de
que rusia intentó interferir en las
elecciones de 2020 y las recompensas
ofrecidas al grupo talibán para matar
soldados estadounidenses en afganistán